l'eau on commence avec un mot unis ben
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire
qu'est ce que c'est un contexte un peu
difficile de deviner puisqu'il n'est pas
non plus c'est que c'est pas un mot du
dictionnaire donc à quoi est ce qu on
fait référence est ce qu'on parle dans
un sport ainsi on parle d'un véhicule
pour vous aider voici sa tradition
monoko i
mais oui on parle de tout ça sont causés
par le cancer des testicules
hélas pour ceux qui en tireront pas
certain de comprendre ce que je sais le
dire on dit qu'une image vaut mille mots
le 8 décembre 2008
hollande même affaire de 26 ans je
rentre à l'hôpital d'urgence parce que
mon test quelle gauche avait atteint la
taille d'une balle de tennis s'empara
sens pas normal
puis pour les ambitieux ici le sport un
but à atteindre non plus bref le 8
décembre celle de la semaine à mon
vingtième anniversaire
j'apprends que j'ai vécues par les
testicules que je vois besoin de
chimiothérapie agressive et qu'en plus
ce qu'on va devoir m'enlever mon
testicules bio à cause de la tumeur et
là c'est vrai que celle de mende
la réponse est oui il y aurait juste une
pin up dans cacahuètes
ce qui m'amène à dire si rien n'était
pas c'est bien mais pas impossible je
suis vivant aujourd'hui alors que jadis
j'étais mourra rien n'est impossible
au secondaire j'ai vécu une intimidation
tellement vicieuse que si j'avais à
choisir entre vivre cette intimidation
là où mon cancer mon cancer avec la
chimio l'opération la douleur le stress
du traducteur
moi je choisirais le cancer à chaque
fois sans hésiter mais mais j'ai réussi
à prendre ces obstacles et les
transformer en source d'espoir et
d'inspiration pour autrui j'ai réussi à
les prendre et à les utiliser ces
obstacles pour faire du bien dans ma
communauté et conférences et
conséquemment suffisamment à faire
carrière de conférencier ma conférence
sur l'intimidation dans laquelle ge
explique qu'on s'en sort en trois ans en
trois ans j'ai donné dans 100 grandes
écoles plus de trente mille jeunes ont
entendu mon message d'espoir oui jadis
j'étais mise misérable mais aujourd'hui
je suis ici un ted et surtout donc rien
n'était possible et surtout moelleux le
gars qui a échoué c'est matt 5,36 voilà
je suis ici là haut a chassé sur
invitation
en plus je sais pas utiliser excel
aujourd'hui on parle de redéfinir son
avenir ah si vous savez comment on
redéfinit son avenir en mes choix
l'échec un énorme valeur parce qu'ils
échouent et où même la peur d'échouer
citant lé plus grand motivateur qui nous
pousse à mieux réussir
donc il va falloir le réaliser et se
l'avouer aujourd'hui l'échec c'est bien
parce que sans ce besoin imminent là de
se dépasser
on serait pas appelé à redéfinir notre
avenir donc aujourd'hui mesdames et
messieurs en brisant un tabou tout leur
sens on va apprendre à accepter l'échec
personnellement ça lui donnait de
connotation négative
on va apprendre à accepter que les gens
autour de nous et chou sans les juger
parce que c'est notre devoir
il ya plusieurs formes d chacun y en a
plusieurs
il ya la faillite le divorce est là j'en
passe vous moi tant qu'enfant du milieu
dans la famille je peux vous le dire
j'ai échoué j'ai joué physiquement par
le cancer j'échoue et socialement parle
est une version j'ai échoué
académiquement ma première année
d'université
ce qui explique pourquoi c'est pas un
avocat qui s'adresse à vous en ce moment
preuve à l'appui que l'échec si bien
jobs dévolu pour ramener sur un titi
sheckler dont je parlais tantôt mon
cancer vous savez quand on apprend qu'on
a le cancer au moment du diagnostic tas
comme vous savez pas mais on prend les
grandes décisions sur le champ on se dit
est ce que ça va me battre ou est-ce que
je vais le battre de cancer
moi j'ai une long seulement décidé de ne
jamais laisser la maladie définir ma
fille mais surtout je décide à prendre
cette maladie là et l'utiliser pour
faire du bien dans la vie des gens
l'échec de la mission
c'est bien et c'est pour ça qu'en
conférence
je le dis tout le temps le cancer c'est
le plus beau cadeau que la vie repos
puma phone
bon c'est ça que si ma conjointe de
molde présence du xive deuxième plus
beau cadeau à chaque année à doha au
qatar se tient au prestigieux sommet sur
l'éducation à tous les ans au moins
avant toutes les sommités mondiales du
domaine de l'éducation se regroupent au
moyen orient comme je dois pour
collaborer travailler ensemble et faire
avancer leur domaine en 2014
on a fait un grand honneur au mieux
inviter et ça a été absolument
absolument merveilleux mais fait que 15
des 1900 personnes qui étaient j'étais
le seul à parler d'intimidation
parce qu'au moins à rien on ne parle pas
d'intimidation comme à plusieurs régions
du mans cet échec social apporte la
honte à la famille donc s'il table avant
trous les juger je veux vous le rappeler
un ici ça fait cinq ans qu'on parle
d'intimidation mais promet à cette
semaine en 2014 un grand thème le thème
la semaine c'était comment adresser les
nouveaux défis de l'éducation et quelle
était la grande recommandations pour y
arriver
mais surprise surprise c'était en
permettant aux jeunes d'échouer c'est
surprenant et même choquant pour
certains un certain mois ça a changé ma
vie parce qu ici comme partout ailleurs
l'échec stone barricades
il va donc falloir créer un grand
changement
parce que notre façon de penser le elle
est expiré notre vision du futur d'antan
ne s'est pas adaptée à la réalité
d'aujourd'hui ni aux événements qui ont
lieu en cours de route
à titre d'exemple en 1995
pensez vous vraiment qu'un avec est
repris d'une si grande augmentation des
inégalités sociales aujourd'hui non son
camp juste au réchauffement climatique
qui est une réalité omniprésente
aujourd'hui et en 1995 on en parlait
mais niveau mais promet à l'échec soit
une nation un concept qu'on connaît tous
ici ans qu'on veuille l'admettre non on
a tous dû à un moment donné faire un
grand changement dans notre vie parce
qu'on avait frappé à mains et son sens
tant le ces gens me plaisent mais c'est
nécessaire
parce que c'est ce moment là cet impact
summer qui nous permet de grandir
il va donc falloir créer ce genre
d'environnement de croissance
personnelle pour nos jeunes pour nous
parce qu'il faut comprendre qu'ils
échouent et ça ne veut pas dire faire
quelque chose de mal de honteux non
c'est un appel au dépassement l'échec
c'est une éventuelle source de fierté
il faut comprendre pour le comprendre
nos obstacle on les aime pas mais c'est
eux qui nous font grandir
l'école doit donc permettre ce genre
d'apprentissage
on est ici en ce moment dans un
établissement ou l'éducation
ce transport s'est transforme
c'est donc ici ainsi partout ailleurs où
on éduque nos futures têtes pensantes
que doit s'entamer ce changement le on
doit moderniser le message
on doit prendre ce qu'on nous a inculqué
dans le passé et l'adapter pour nous
permettre de passer à cette prochaine
étape ce qui urge
je voulais dit tantôt notre façon de
penser elle est désuet mais avant tout
ce changement le dos par ici doit se
faire à la maison
le changement dont je parle et je dis
beaucoup de mon changement le sec mais
le changement dont jeu phare faut
comprendre oui il est un intellectuel
absolument mais avant tout est lisse
sociale le papa de karl marx des khmers
rouges indignement sociale et pas quand
je parle de ce moulin de ce changement
social heures 4 heures d'un mouvement
c'est un mouvement c'est un mouvement
d'amour et de compassion que l'on doit
nourrir et propager il faut commencer à
jouer notre rôle de guide pour les
prochaines générations
il faut en nous encourager l'empathie
pour que les jeunes qui nous observent
recommence en faire preuve parce que
contrairement à ce qu'on nous dit pierse
que plein de gens pensent les jeunes
font preuve d'une grande sensibilité
texte est important de comprendre ça
mais en même temps oui oui des fois sans
son coffre les gens qui fuient des fois
faut creuser un peu plus pour la trouver
sa sensibilité mais si nous on donné un
meilleur exemple à tyco leur
comportement a eu un échange serait
aussi ce qui est surprenant dans la face
à ce mouvement là ce que ce mouvement là
il prend pied dans la nouvelle tendance
économique qu'on appelle l'économie
sociale et que moi j'affectionne a
surnommé le capitalisme social 2.0 et
c'est encore plus surprenant c'est que
les résultats de ce mouvement là ils
sont quantifiables en chiffres et en
dehors surtout je m'explique le
capitalisme concept qu'on connaît tous
ces concepts qu'on connaît bien et si on
en parle un peu on peut dire que c'est
une forme d'autodétermination dans
l'histoire moderne
le capitaliste c'est leur moyen ou un
des moyens principaux qu'on a pris pour
se prendre en main et si on vulgarise le
concept du capitalisme ça veut dire
faire un travail en échange d'une
rémunération mais mon capital social 2.0
il veut la même chose on fait un travail
tout le monde en somme entre à la
collaboration et les résultats de ce
travail là bas ils sont chiffrables
en d'autres mots on travaille comme
faisait tout le monde ensemble on
s'investit dans la communauté pour créer
un mouvement qui est payant je vous
donne un exemple
le plus bel exemple que je pourrais pas
vous donner ma conférence sur
l'intimidation quand on fait ce genre de
travail là on se dit toujours que si on
a est un jeune on a fait le travail
notre but à travers toutes nos années de
notre carrière cdans et d un authentique
je voulais dire ma conférence j'allais
donner dans 130 écoles et en moyenne
cinq jeunes par école vient de m'avoir
après la conférence pour me dire que
cette dernière les avait réellement
aider qu'elle leur avait donné espoir
est permis de ne pas abandonner sa ses
650 jeunes qui ont eu de l'aide grâce à
la confiance
de plus un gène en moyenne par école
mais cris plus tôt par la suite pour
maintenant la même chose que la
conférence l'avait réellement aidé pour
un total de 130 jeunes de plus pour un
total final de 780 jeunes qui ont pu
avoir espoir et ne pas avoir mené grâce
à la conférence
et si on se dit que 10% de ses 780
jeunes là ont décidé de ne pas décrocher
on n'est pas abandonnée parce que je
dois vous le dire un gel intime d c'est
un jeune qui veut plus aller à l'école
mais si on dit que 10 % de ces jeunes
ont décidé de ne pas décrocher on se
retrouve avec 78 m 78 ans qui ne sont
pas des décrocheurs aujourd'hui et voici
le punch si nous en cherchons le voici
ce que l'économiste pierre fortin a
estimé récemment qu un décrocheur pour
l'ensemble de sa vie va coûter à l'état
quatre cent cinquante mille dollars donc
si on fait le calcul
on réalise que ma conférence
j'adore ça disait que c'est de l'argent
contre des villes mais elle a permis à
l'état n'est pas rien et 35 millions $
35 millions qu'on peut réinvestir dans
notre société
ça c'est extraordinaire mais ça c'est
une personne imaginez si tous les
canadiens canadien tous les québécois et
québécoises joueuses et leur porte
magisson cydia tout que on aiderait un
janot courant de vie juste imaginer
l'impact imaginer le futur qu'on
laisserait aux enfants de nos enfants si
on jouait tous en fête son faisait tous
notre part on se retrouve avec un
mouvement qui non seulement nous
permettre de redéfinir notre ami mais
qui nous permettraient de redéfinir
l'avenir des prochaines générations et
sommet ambitieux c'est ce qu'on appelle
une révolution et la révolution je
voulais des tentes aux apports à la
maison et je parle en connaissance de
cause
moi j'ai des parents qui m'ont toujours
encouragé edmond envers autrui et à ne
jamais abandonner une charge jésus
enfantin parce que s'il fait le relais
sont de celles-là sont là je serais pas
ici aujourd'hui et surtout pas vous dire
si belles paroles et le plus beau cadeau
que mes parents m'ont laissé ceux qui
m'ont toujours permis de les voir comme
il était temps salem al salem al sont
jamais caché puis par moments oui on les
a vu échouer pour par la suite par
exemple les voit mieux réussi bel
exemple de réussite rsa maillon accompli
quelque chose d'extraordinaire ils ont
vendu leur entreprise s'ils ont pu
léguer alors par air toute ma
reconnaissance pour karine ce peuple est
extrêmement bien maintenant évidemment
ils sont fait une petite retraite rien
foule
on s'entend retraite à bill gates
mais s'il était devenu multimilliardaire
sont adonnés les nouveaux bill gates du
québec la femme et du boul mais la
grande leçon que je tire est de leur
exemple c'est pas que si tu vends ton
entreprise un jour de se faire de
l'argent ou que le succès revient à
travers ce qui est un peu près aussi la
grande leçon que je tire de leur exemple
c'est que peu importe
l'adversité malgré tous les obstacles de
grands monuments peuvent être bâties
rien n'est impossible
et là je vous laisse sur deux belles
citations et par la suite une grande
question que j'espère vous faire
réfléchir ceux ci citation là me suivre
partout je donne à mon travail dans la
vie en général
la première c'est la suivante seuls les
gens qui sont assez fous pour penser
qu'ils peuvent changer le monde sont
ceux qui réussissent alpha on est
inconnue le petit a rappelé aux mcl ses
débuts et la deuxième citation
là je vous avertis vous allez
probablement trouvé ce brillant ont fait
l'histoire et les récits des gens
ordinaires qui ont décidé de faire leur
part et les tragédies qui a conduit ce
temps des gens extraordinaires qui ont
refusé d'agir quand je la veux dire rien
je sais
ma question est donc la suivante à la
lumière surtout de cette station lol
n vous fout n vous assez fou pour faire
une exception
elle vous assez faut pour sortir de
votre outil juste une fois
êtes vous assez fou pour sortir de votre
zone de confort juste assez pour
contribuer à ce grand changement là et à
ce mouvement
bref mesdames messieurs posez vous cette
question là jusqu'où peut aller votre
folie merci beaucoup